Bonjour!
Dans mon épisode 2 de Chroniques de Prof
j'avais brièvement parlé des maladies au
Moyen-Âge, mais... C'était l'épisode 2...
J'étais jeune et innocente...
-Dis surtout que j'avais pas encore eu le
temps de t'apprendre la vie.
-Et la mort, en l’occurrence, puisque aujourd'hui
on va parler de la peste noire qui était
plutôt mortelle.
-D'ailleurs je traîne une petite fièvre
depuis que je suis arrivée ici...
-Humour.
-C'est parti.
La peste noire qui débarque dans nos contrées
en 1347 n'est pas la première épidémie
qu'aient connu les européens. Ils avaient
l'habitude de rencontrer la rougeole, la petite
vérole, la variole...
Ces maladies étaient récurrentes mais ceux
qui y survivaient restaient immunisés, donc
logiquement ils n'en tombaient malades qu'une
fois. Par contre ces maladies restaient en
eux, ce qui explique que par la suite les
natifs américains aient été décimés lorsque
les européens découvrent l'Amérique.
-Mais en échange ils nous ont probablement
filé la syphilis.
*attrapez les toutes, Aliénor retourne sa
casquette*
Parmi les maladies dont on a connaissance
on peut aussi citer la peste antonine, vers
165, qui fait des ravages dans l'Empire romain.
D'après sa description par de nombreux auteurs,
et notamment le médecin Galien qui l'a soignée,
il pourrait en fait s'agir de la variole.
En 541 l'Europe connaît sa première pandémie
avec la peste de Justinien, qui revient par
cycles jusque 760 et provoque un effondrement
démographique dans l'Empire romain d'Orient.
Cette fois on est sûrs qu'il s'agissait de
la peste bubonique, grâce à des squelettes
sur lesquels on a retrouvé l'ADN de yersinia
pestis.
On peut aussi mentionner la lèpre, qui est
très connue et déjà citée dans la Bible.
Cependant, on n'est pas certains qu'elle ait
existé en Europe occidentale avant l'apparition
de la peste: dans les léproseries qui ont
été fouillées, très peu de squelettes
présentent les déformations osseuses dues
à la peste, il est donc possible que le terme
de lèpre ait été utilisé pour recouvrir
tout un tas de maladies.
Vers 1300, les européens ont donc l'habitude
d'épidémies récurrentes et ont déjà connu
quelques bonnes grosses épidémies.
-Enfin la peste de Justinien remonte à cinq
siècles, alors excuse-nous mais on en avait
pas un souvenir très précis non plus.
-Certes. De plus à cette époque la densité
humaine en Europe occidentale était très
forte, ce qui fait qu'on créait de plus en
plus de champs pour se nourrir mais du coup
les sols étaient épuisés, le rendement
en grains déclinait, les récoltes étaient
insuffisantes, et c'était souvent la famine.
Voilà pour le contexte.
-En plus c'était le début du petit âge
glaciaire, qui dure du XIIIe au XIXe siècle.
Donc on avait faim, et froid. Mais on n'était
pas encore malade alors tout va bien!
-Oui ben on y vient: passons maintenant
aux années 1340, où tout commence.
Les premières pestes que j'ai citées, la
peste de Justinien notamment, venaient probablement
d'Afrique. La peste noire vient d'ailleurs:
d'Asie, et plus précisément de Mongolie.
Dans ces régions se trouvent différentes
espèces de marmottes, qui pourraient avoir
été les porteuses des puces pestiférées.
On parle de puces qui résistaient à -25°
et à des jeûnes de dix mois.
-Ce sont donc les nemesis des Européens qui
en cette période, je le rappelle, avaient
faim et froid.
-A partir de 1320, la peste se déclare en
Mongolie et en Chine et fait déjà des ravages,
mais n'est pas encore transmise aux européens.
Pourtant dans les années 1260, des liens
s'étaient noués, des marchands génois se
rendent en Asie (coucou Marco Polo) et tracent
une nouvelle route terrestre jusqu'à la Chine
qu'on appelle plus tard la Route de la Soie.
Sur cette route de la soie se trouve l'étape
de La Tana, petite ville fouillée en 1885.
On découvre que dans les années 1338-1339
la ville a connu une forte mortalité: sur
trois pierres tombales, il est carrément
écrit que ces personnes sont mortes de la
peste.
La Tana pourrait donc être le village à
partir duquel la peste se répand en Europe,
puisqu'il menait ensuite à Kaffa où les
génois avaient établi un comptoir marchand.
En 1345, la ville de Kaffa est assiégée
par les troupes de Yannibeg, un chef mongol.
Pas de chance pour lui, ses troupes ont la
peste! Une anecdote raconte que Yannibeg
aurait catapulté ses morts par dessus les
murailles de Kaffa, ce qui en ferait un premier
cas de guerre bactériologique.
Mais il est plus probable que la peste soit
juste passée du camp de siège à la ville
et comme il s'agissait d'une ville marchande
elle a eu tout le loisir de contaminer le
reste de l'Europe ensuite.
-Plaisir d'offrir, joie de recevoir.
En octobre 1347, un bateau génois accoste
à Messine mais pas de bol ses marins sont
soit mourants, soit morts. Comme on n'a pas
encore trop compris le truc, surtout qu'on
était en octobre et que les épidémies étaient
rares en hiver, ça continue:
en 1348 la peste arrive à Marseille et s'étend
ensuite par voie terrestre. Elle touche la
France entière, puis les Pays-Bas, franchit
la Manche, puis voyage en Norvège, en Suède...
En 1350 elle s'est étendue jusqu'en Écosse,
aux Orcades, aux îles Féroé et Shetland,
et même en Islande et au Groenland.
Et finalement... On ne sait pas vraiment de
quel virus il s'agissait ni si c'était vraiment
la peste.
-FAKE CHRONICLES! Les médias vous mentent.
-Cette peste a disparu au début du XVIIIe
siècle en Europe, alors on n'est sûrs de
rien. D'après les descriptions qu'en ont
fait les chroniqueurs il pourrait aussi s'agir
de l'anthrax, de la tuberculose, de la typhoïde
ou du typhus.
Comme la peste est transmise par des rongeurs,
pour qu'il y ait une épidémie il faut que
des rongeurs meurent et que les puces migrent
vers les humains: or certains chroniqueurs
musulmans et chinois signalent des morts massives
de rats, mais aucun européen.
De plus la peste bubonique met 2 à 8 jours
à incuber: c'est court, ce qui ne devrait
pas laisser à un malade le temps de voyager
de ville en ville et de la transmettre:
mystère, donc.
Il existe trois types de peste principaux,
et exceptionnellement je n'illustrerai pas
mes propos: la peste bubonique laisse 25
à 30% de chances de guérison, mais elle
est transmise par les puces et pas entre hommes
donc on en revient à notre interrogation:
est-ce que c'était vraiment ça?
Il existe aussi la peste pulmonaire, quand
le bacille se trouve dans les poumons. Celle-ci
est transmissible entre hommes grâce aux
crachats de liquides présents dans les poumons,
et tue dans 95% des cas.
-Je peux faire la dernière? La peste septicémique
est la phase terminale, quand le bacille est
dans le sang. Elle provoque l'éclatement
des vaisseaux sanguins et est toujours mortelle.
-Quoi qu'il en soit on ignore de quelle peste
il s'agissait. Il pourrait s'agir d'un virus
mutant, ou même d'une mutation humaine, et
notre population descendrait alors d'une souche
immunisée contre la peste.
Les contemporains de la peste s'interrogent
aussi sur ses origines, mais ils ne vont pas
vraiment chercher dans le domaine médical.
Ils vont chercher du côté de l'astrologie,
ou encore des tremblements de terre ou des
éruptions volcaniques qui auraient déchiré
la terre et libéré des vapeurs mortelles.
Ici, le tremblement de terre de Bâle en 1356.
Ils accusent aussi des groupes de personnes:
les juifs, parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
médecins juifs alors bouh c'est suspect,
mais aussi les immigrés, les tanneurs, les
bouchers, les prostituées et les homosexuels,
c'est la grande paranoïa.
-Heureusement que la société a évolué
depuis.
-Puisque toutes ces accusations ne mènent
pas à grand chose, étonnamment, on va aussi
chercher la vérité dans les livres.
On commence par la Bible: on y trouve les
sept plaies d’Égypte, mais aussi des plaies
envoyées par Dieu durant l'errance des israélites
chaque fois qu'ils refusaient de faire confiance
aux prêtres.
-Sur votre arrêt de travail je met «punition
divine», et comme ordonnance vous ferez
repentance et prierez beaucoup. Ça fera dix
livres!
-Selon les médecins et clercs qui s'intéressent
à la peste, elle ne cible même pas juste
les individus coupables mais tout un peuple,
contrairement à la lèpre qui était considérée
comme une punition divine individuelle.
Durant les premiers temps de l'apparition
de la peste, on cherche donc à comprendre
sa cause mais assez peu son traitement. Il
existait pourtant de chouettes traités de
médecine datant de l'Antiquité qui auraient
pu leur être utiles, comme un traité de
Thucydide sur la peste d'Athènes, mais ils
sont peu étudiés.
Du côté de l'Orient on s'en sort légèrement
mieux: alors que l'Occident a délaissé
le monde antique depuis un moment, l'Orient
a conservé de nombreux traités et a encore
connaissance d'épidémies du VIIe, VIIIe
siècle...
Par exemple les musulmans considèrent que
personne ne doit fuir un endroit pestiféré
ou s'y rendre, alors qu'en Occident on a d'abord
tendance à se barrer et donc contaminer d'autres
endroits.
La peste touche surtout les villes, certaines
plus que d'autres sans qu'on sache toujours
pourquoi: à Moscou la première épidémie
tue 31% de la population, 60% à Venise, 40%
à Milan qui impose vite des restrictions
à l'entrée de la ville... En moyenne, les
pertes dans les villes sont de 40%. Le grand-duc
de Moscou et le patriarche de l’Église
orthodoxe sont tués, ainsi que le roi Alphonse
XI de Castille qui est le seul roi européen
à mourir de la peste.
-Ça a dû le faire pester.
-Le problème, c'est que la Grande Mort ou
Grande Pestilence comme on l'appelait à l'époque
n'a pas fait que frapper une fois: elle
frappe vers 1350, mais revient ensuite en
1361 où elle tue à nouveau 20% de la population,
puis vers 1370 où elle re-tue 10 à 15% de
la population... Jusqu'à la fin du XVe siècle,
elle revient tous les 6 à 12 ans, touchant
encore une fois surtout les villes.
Du coup, la société n'a jamais le temps
de se relever: jusque 1500 un individu est
exposé deux à quatre fois à la peste au
cours de sa vie. Après cette date les épidémies
s'espacent, tous les 15 ou 20 ans tout de
même, mais restent tout aussi meurtrières.
A cause de ces pestes les dirigeants des villes
ont tendance à fuir vers la campagne, ce
qui provoque parfois des révoltes chez ceux
qui restent.
-Y'a plus personne ! Y'a eu un virus ou quoi
?
-Les dernières grandes apparitions de cette
peste sont en 1665 à Londres, où 20% de
la population est tuée. L'épidémie provoque
la fuite de nombreux habitants, surtout les
riches, le roi évidemment...
-Mais bon, heureusement l’Église trouve
le coupable: la république de Cromwell.
Fallait pas déconner avec la monarchie, on
vous avait prévenus!
-Et puis, pas de bol, un an plus tard a lieu
le Grand incendie de Londres de 1666.
-Fallait vraiment pas déconner!
Heureusement, on finit par comprendre certaines
choses sur la peste et à mener des actions
un poil plus efficaces que la prière collective.
On commence à avoir recours à des quarantaines,
des certificats de santé, et à améliorer
l'hygiène urbaine. Les États italiens sont
les plus efficaces en la matière: à partir
du milieu du XVe siècle ils communiquent
même en temps de guerre sur les villes malades
ou non, et on doit fournir un certificat de
bonne santé pour rentrer dans une ville.
On crée de nouvelles structures pour mettre
en quarantaine les hommes, les marchandises
et les bateaux, et dans beaucoup de villes
on impose aux familles de déclarer leurs
décès et parfois d'en donner la cause.
Lorsqu'il y a un mort dans une famille, des
personnels spécialisés viennent les chercher
et leurs biens sont brûlés.
-Bring out your deads !
-Les familles des victimes se retrouvent alors
en quarantaine, soit chez elles, soit dans
une maison de pestiférés aussi appelée
lazaret.
Il faut donc imaginer que dans les villes
atteintes par une épidémie, on avait des
tas de familles qui étaient enfermées chez
elles à attendre que ça se passe. Ou que
ça se passe pas, d'ailleurs.
L’État est obligé de les nourrir évidemment,
ce qui coûte super cher, et en plus comme
pendant l'épidémie ces personnes ne travaillent
pas elles ne peuvent pas payer d'impôts:
c'est la misère.
Heureusement certaines personnes font parfois
des dons à ces villes, ou bien on crée un
impôt «spécial peste» comme à Lille.
A la fin du Moyen-Âge, l'Italie est la plus
en avance en matière de santé et l'Angleterre
est en retard.
En France des règlements spéciaux sont mis
en place, et des hôpitaux sont construits
comme l'hôpital Saint-Louis vers 1610. Là
encore l'Italie était en avance: l'hôpital
de Milan, ici à l'écran et construit en
1488, pouvait accueillir 16 000 malades.
-On ne vous cache pas qu'ils étaient un peu
serrés.
-Les médecins faisaient surtout de la prévention
mais peu de thérapie, et de toute façon
elle n'était pas très efficace.
-Comment ça ma thérapie n'est pas efficace?
Un petit remède à base de vinaigre et d'oignons
ça vous remet sur pieds, et si vraiment ça
ne passe pas on pourra tester le mercure ou
l'arsenic.
J'ai aussi un petit elixir à base de venin
de scorpion qui vient d'arriver! Par contre,
restez loin. C'est mieux. On sait jamais.
-Parfois, malgré les mesures en place...
Ça merdait. C'est le cas lors de la dernière
grande épidémie de peste à Marseille en
1720.
-Comme si la peste voulait terminer à l'endroit
même où elle avait commencé.
Le 31 janvier 1720, un bateau quitte Sidon
avec un certificat de santé en ordre mais
apprend ensuite que la peste s'y est déclarée
quelques jours après son départ. Il connaît
quelques pertes en cours de route et s'attend
à être mis en quarantaine à Marseille,
mais ce n'est pas le cas. Des bateaux continuent
d'arriver du Moyen-Orient, où la peste sévit,
mais on les laisse décharger tranquille.
-Non mais franchement, ça ressemblait pas
à la peste. Et je m'y connais.
-Les autorités commencent à s'inquiéter
et décident de déplacer tout ce beau monde
sur l'île de Jarre, où on mettait les gens
en quarantaine, mais c'est un peu tard:
on commence à se rendre compte qu'une épidémie
couve, mais on essaie de la cacher, les malades
sont transportés au lazaret de nuit, on parle
de morts suspectes...
-Mais les habitants ne sont pas cons, et puisqu'on
passe en juillet à environ 350 cadavres par
jour ils se doutent bien que ça sent le roussi.
-Je vois pas le problème, sûrement la canicule.
-Bon, on peut reconnaître aux médecins que
la plupart restent en ville pour soigner les
malades, merci pour eux.
-Ah ben quand même.
-Comme beaucoup d'épidémies celle-ci provoque
l'endettement de la ville, des problèmes
de ravitaillement, l'ouverture d'hôpitaux...
On propose à des galériens d'être libérés
pour débarrasser les rues des morts, puisqu'en
août on passe à 1000 morts par jour.
-Ils ne devaient pas être d'une forme olympique.
-Quoi?
-De Marseille.
-Le savon?
-Non, l'Olympique.
-Du coup les gens sortent de chez eux avec
des bâtons de Saint Roch, des bâtons de
2m de long pour maraver les passants qui risqueraient
de les toucher. Ou juste pour les tenir éloignés.
-En septembre la situation semble se calmer,
les riches reviennent, mais juste à ce moment
là la peste frappe le quartier riche de la
ville.
-Loi de Murphy bonjour.
-Et finalement vers octobre l'épidémie se
calme, on brûle tous les tissus contaminés
et on mure les cryptes des églises qui ont
servi de cimetière. C'était quand même
un beau bordel qui aurait pu être contenu
si la quarantaine avait été appliquée dès
le départ, et ça aurait pu éviter que 56%
de la population décède.
Évidemment toutes les mesures citées pour
limiter la peste n'étaient pas parfaitement
efficaces, sinon y'aurait peut-être plus
eu d'épidémie, mais elles montrent une modernisation
des États en matière de santé, avec le
début des inspections sanitaires et de l'enregistrement
des décès.
Comme dans tout processus de modernisation,
il y a des résistances: certaines familles
déterrent leurs morts de la peste pour les
ré-enterrer dans le cimetière familial,
ou encore les fossoyeurs qui habituellement
pouvaient garder le plus beau vêtement du
défunt sont dégs parce qu'en cas de peste
les vêtements sont brûlés.
La peste noire a des tas de conséquences
sur la société plus ou moins directes et
évidentes.
-Emploi: le marché du travail s'effondre,
et les temps d'apprentissage d'un métier
sont diminués pour pas que l'apprenti meure
avant d'avoir fini.
-Religion: avant la peste la formation du
clergé s'était progressivement élevée,
beaucoup étaient allés à l'université...
A cause de la première vague de peste, le
niveau général d'éducation des prêtres
diminue pendant plusieurs dizaines d'années.
-Un prêtre sur 10 abandonne son poste, parce
que ça va bien les conneries.
-On manque d'ailleurs tellement de prêtres
que l'évêque de Bath écrit en 1349 qu'une
personne qui se sent partir peut se confesser
à n'importe qui, même une femme.
-En Allemagne apparaissent des flagellants,
des types qui se déplacent en bande, font
des rondes autour des églises en chantant
puis se jettent à terre pour se flageller.
C'est une autre culture.
-Ecologie! Grâce ou à cause de la désertification
des villages, les loups agrandissent leurs
territoires et arrivent dans les faubourgs
de Paris en 1420.
-Agriculture: puisqu'il y a moins de besoins
en nourriture, bah oui, tout le monde est
mort, les paysans se diversifient dans le
bétail et créent de nouvelles inventions
pour remplacer la main d’œuvre disparue.
-Mode! Certains produits comme la soie deviennent
plus facile à trouver, des «lois somptuaires»
empêchent les gens de s'habiller au dessus
de leur condition parce que ça plaisait pas
trop aux nobles de voir des pécores s'habiller
comme eux.
-Art: les représentations de danses macabres
sont grave à la mode.
-Santé: une forte suspicion à l'égard
des médecins subsiste, jusqu'à de nos jours.
-Société: les gens vont au cabaret et
se bourrent la gueule en pensant à Epicure.
La peste noire, la deuxième pandémie, prend
fin au XVIIe siècle. La troisième pandémie
éclate à Canton, en Asie, en 1894 et ne
touche que l'Orient.
Elle atteint Hong-Kong, l'Inde, et on trouve
quelques cas en Australie, Afrique du Sud,
au Portugal à cause des liens commerciaux
avec l'Asie, et trois cas à Vienne qui sont
plutôt WTF.
Cette peste disparaît en 1948 après avoir
fait 12 millions de victimes, mais grâce
à elle le bactériologique Alexandre Yersin
parvient à isoler le bacille de la peste,
à l'identifier et à produire un sérum.
-Et à lui donner son nom. Yersinia pestis,
ça s'invente pas.
-De nos jours on rapporte quelques cas par
an de peste bubonique, mais ils sont rarement
mortels. La peste ne figure donc pas parmi
les maladies totalement éradiquées, contrairement
à la variole qui a été reconnue éradiquée
en 1990 seulement.
Qui sait, de telles épidémies pourraient
réapparaître. Quand on voit les réactions
des médias et du public face à certains
débuts d'épidémies, comme la peste à Bombay
en 1990 ou le SRAS en Asie en 2003, on voit
bien que la menace d'une grande épidémie
mortelle fait peur.
-Surtout si elle vient d'Afrique ou d'Asie.
Et si elle risque de toucher des Occidentaux.
-T'as vite appris, mine de rien.
Cette peur des maladies est d'autant plus
grande que certaines nous sont transmises
par d'autres animaux. On partage des pathologies
avec de nombreux animaux, et le cas de la
vache folle par exemple fait peur justement
parce qu'il est transmis par les bovins à
l'homme, qu'on n'en sait pas grand chose et
qu'il résiste aux traitements.
C'est un cas comme celui là qui laisse à
penser que certaines maladies peuvent être
dues à des virus mutants, c'était peut-être
le cas de la peste noire qui aurait aussi
pu disparaître du fait d'une autre mutation.
-Celle des X-Men.
-Maiiis j'étais sur une fin sérieuse là!
Bon, ben, merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au
bout cette vidéo pleine de bonne humeur et
la prochaine devrait traiter d'un sujet un
petit peu moins démoralisant.
J'en profite aussi, comme la chaîne existe
depuis deux ans, pour lancer une FAQ. Si vous
avez des questions à me poser, posez-les
en commentaire, et j'y répondrai dans une
prochaine FAQ. Voilà. En attendant portez-vous
bien, n'allez pas
sur Doctissimo si vous vous sentez mal après
avoir vu cette vidéo, à bientôt et place
à la musique !